hello we begin with breaking news at
this hour explosions have been reported
in Yemen's Capital sah and the port city
of Huda us officials say American and
British troops have launched strikes
against targets linked to the houis
there it is the first time strikes have
been carried out against the Iran back
group since it started attacking ships
in the Red Sea late last year the houis
claim they're only targeting ships
linked to Israel in response to the war
on Gaza before the strikes the group's
leader vowed to respond to any so-called
aggression we will not hesitate to do
everything we can and we will confront
the American aggression any American
aggression will never remain without a
response and the response will not only
be at the level of the recent operation
that targeted Americans at Sea with more
than 24 drones and several missiles the
response will be greater than that and
more than that and with that we are more
determined to continue and Target ships
link to Israel we will not back down
from that and our position stems from
our faith the Americans should know what
that means oh we've got correspondence
covering this on both sides of the
Atlantic Villa Marx is in London tonight
but first let's Closs to Washington DC
and speak to shihab ratansi so sheab any
comment uh from the US on
this no comment as far as we can see as
as yet the position of the
Administration has been the same for a
week now there will be consequences for
the houthis if they continue to attack
shipping in the Red Sea in the Gulf of
Aiden it was repeated by Anthony blinkin
during his tour of the region on
Wednesday we understand that Congress
was briefed earlier today Thursday here
in the United States and but the
interesting thing is that the White
House Press pool was told to go home
just about an hour ago which is kind
interesting because that would suggest
that then we're not going to have any
official statements from the Joe Biden
as he launches another another war or he
gets involved in another war in the in
the region he starts bombing Yemen
remember Joe Biden he was the candidate
who said he was going to end endless
Wars specifically in the Middle East
specifically in Yemen actually that was
a major part of his campaign was to stop
the war in in Yemen but now he again
like the the two presidents before him
is bombing Yemen or at least involved in
the bombing the bombing of Yemen and
clearly then he's not terribly keen on
facing the cameras it would PR
tonight and uh what they said earlier
how mean how how how are they uh at this
point separating this from the defensive
uh Prosperity Guardian uh Mission which
is what the the mission that they've
been carrying out for for several weeks
now uh to repel the houti attacks in the
Red
Sea it was really striking how the
Pentagon spokesperson when asked about
all the rumors that were circulating
about the imminence of us strikes on
Yemen how his main concern seemed to be
to separate any US military action on
Yemen from operation Prosperity Guardian
operation Prosperity Guardian is this
attempt by the US to get a coalition
together to patrol the Red Sea and the
Gulf of Aiden and it's been doing really
badly key allies have said no we're not
going to take part or if we do Patrol
we'll do it by ourselves and part of
that was because there was a suspicion
that if there was some International
Coalition in the area it would be used
as some sort of some sort of fig leaf
for a US escalation in the region even
as the Biden Administration says it
doesn't that's the one thing it doesn't
want is to is to accelerate the conflict
further from from gaza's Gaza and the
West Bank's borders so this is kind of
the reason why so many allies seem to
say no we don't want to be a part of
this it and so what the what the
Pentagon Spokes and says was look if
there is any offensive action taken on
Yemen it's purely The Sovereign decision
of individual Nations it has nothing to
do with prosperity Guardian that's
purely defensive it's like the highway
patrol so don't get don't get that
confused and I can see that the Pentagon
was rather concerned there because not
only will that will will will this
action by potentially deter further
cooperation with the US in the region
because other countries do not want to
be part of a wider Regional War but it
might even make some drop out all right
for the moment sheab thanks very much
sheab rany live for us in Washington